we're leaving for guys have command
command of themselves commanded their
minds commander the ball and ultimately
the command of their team you find those
guys you pour your life into you pour
the resources of people have spent a
lifetime coaching playing this position
and what you've learned is now the have
better command of their future teams or
college teams or pro teams and will
extend that influence to all the people
that they have influence over
that's the beauty of the Lila
we hear it we say it we believe it but
can we see the it factor the games
online you can see in a person's eyes
it's noticeable
if great competitors find a way
the effector you can call it swagger
called preparation I'm gonna call hard
work and i'ma call it consistency they
make the players around them better
the effector welcome to the in factory
how many have ever heard of the phrase
the it factor there's the most
undefinable phrase in the history of
sports and performance sometimes you can
see it B can't describe it our staff
we're looking for those undefinable
traits all the intangible elements we
will be evaluating yes this is a
quarterback competition we are looking
for the not just they 11 best
quarterback the top competitors in the
entire country
that 11 out of the last 13 Heisman
Trophy winners have been elite 11
quarterbacks 10 out of the last 13
national championship teams were
quarterback by elite 11 quarterbacks all
right the last seven guys taken number
one quarterbacks taken number one in the
draft including golf this year Elite 11
quarterbacks 26 out of 32 starters in
the NFL Elite 11 quarterbacks we
traveled around the country we had 14
different regional camps big major
markets are very Los Angeles Dallas
Atlanta Miami New York New Jersey DC all
over the country every weekend in the
spring February through May put your
cleats on step out on this football
field and like I like to tell them hey
five stars three stars no stars that
doesn't matter to us we want to see kids
with our own eyeballs our goal of the
late 11 and Nike supports us to go
around the country and give everyone a
chance I mean with several thousand try
to get into a regional workout but some
of them are in fourth grade and we're
not ready for that the elite 11 does a
good job of giving kids more tools in
their toolbox to get to where they want
to be which ultimately is the NFL you
look at the brand it's 14 first-round
picks that's I mean there's schools that
don't have 14 first-round picks we
combined the evaluation of their film
which is a huge part of it for us it's
50% 25% on what we see your performance
at the regional camp and then 25% as
well in the physical traits so combining
all those metrics that's how we come up
with the list of the 24 that come out to
join us in Los Angeles for the elite 11
finals this is a cam petition our camp
Learning Park competition
I want to see who has it
in LA it's early season regionals I mean
it's the second regional of the year and
some of these guys come and they expect
to dominate and earn their way right
away but you still got to earn it with
us
good job good job good job okay good
good good no shot my experience at the
LA regionals I came out kind of little
nervous a little tight don't slide
through step through
I wasn't having falling I wasn't me out
there
chase Garber's is gonna be my MVP yeah
he kind of came from the bottom and
worked his way above Sears you know he
kind of earned his way up there our
second is like to the Elite 11 finals
for Bishop Gorman Tay Martel Jack is a
dude but that day you didn't have it
I did not invite another
the quarterback position is very
artistic and I think they Chris Roberson
exactly that I consider his play almost
abstract art he's poetry in motion when
you look at him creatively that's how
his mind operates and have you ever been
around an artist when they get into
their flow when they get another zone no
one can touch them I'm getting invited
today he's got a juice about him that
not too many other guys in this class do
I step on this video I shot my man so I
came out the wound to compete he is
different he's not a hundred percent
football like all these guys he has a
lot of interests you had three people
dead or alive to go to dinner with
tonight who would they be
Elton John John Lennon hate not asking
the quarterbacks unconventional
questions it's just another way to gauge
their personality another way to gauge
what do they prioritize in their life
how many instruments you put come on for
the musicians you just named yeah but I
just said I listen to music like 24/7
every year we have a kid that beats the
tune of their own drum
chris is that kid butterflies it's what
I feed inside my other side it's a
little goofy I just like to have fun
I'm good with what makes a quarterback
great is we have conviction with who you
are that I'm comfortable being me I
think Chris fits into that he will be at
his best when people let him be his
eccentric self BP mesquite or Chris
Robeson good job buddy nice work we're
all good quarterbacks but I feel like
I'm the best in the nation
some kids that come out to the regionals
and have nerves or they're they're
looking around and worrying about what
other guys are doing and how they're
throwing when we saw Davis mills at the
Charlotte regional the regional for him
was just another workout oh he can throw
I'm trying to think back to some of the
most polished guys we've had Andrew Luck
was awfully polished a few years back I
think Davis is right there he not been
is just like injury love it
it's like freaky I think that Davis
Mills high school highlight tape is the
best highlight tape that I've evaluated
it's really nothing that jumps out that
he can't do what we look at when we
evaluate base balance load being able to
control the ball being on the plane
conflict disassociating your upper and
lower half he checks the box on
everything and when I'm watching his
film I catalogue probably over 10 throws
that or elite-level throws you're saying
this kid did not only control the ball
you can control mighty controlled
environment and he's gonna be a big-time
player at Stanford here's one for you
three people better alive you can pick
the brain on anything you want because I
can today tonight Oh probably Martin
Luther King
George Washington and Kanye West
honey West yeah obviously it's different
it's different yeah what do you ask does
some of the decisions he is and like how
public he is with everything yeah just
how he deals with all the critics and
stuff you just fill in the blanks that
you value as quarterback traits and he
has them but I think bigger than that
he's got a super quiet line and then the
noise never gets too loud the pressure
never gets too intense I think he cares
as much as anybody I think life is
bigger than this position if I throw an
interception I'm I'm fine if I throw a
touchdown I'm not gonna celebrate and go
crazy it's just fun to be out there and
keep a calm head and be the man for your
team his size his frame I mean just
prototypical and I felt first-round
draft pick he's my number one and if I
had to start the program he would be my
guy
you